hello everyone hope you're all having an
excellent saturday as this game it's uh
well it's basically out of this world
it's uh not only the best game from
round 10 uh from the last round of the
2021 norway chess but also i believe
this is the best game of the tournament
um you guys will be the judge of that
it's alireza ferruga versus the richard
rapport and before we check out the game
uh we have to keep in mind that both uh
well since uh carlos and nepo are about
to play their own game we know how it
finished but when the this game was
being played that we of course did not
know how it will finish so both alireza
and richard have a chance of winning the
tournament so that is also something
that will be taking into consideration
while uh discussing the moves now that
being said let's check it out ferruccio
with the white pieces opens with e4
uh we have c five rapper goes for the uh
sicilian defense knight to f3 knight to
c6 and now uh bishop to b5 going after
the uh medina of rosolimo attack knight
to f6 and now knight to c3 defending
this spawn and now usually black will go
queen to c7 uh nice square for the queen
maybe g6 but here in this game we have
knight the d4 so already starting to
waste tempi with black out of the
opening uh but it uh it's a known movie
it's been played before and it's been
played by a very very strong player it's
been played by magnus cross and himself
uh two years ago in the 2019 which s um
well uh this exact same tournament uh
but in an armageddon game against
caruana but we're going to discuss that
a little bit uh
later on so here we have e5 challenging
the night knight captures on b5 knight
captures and now knight to d5 and this
is the position that was reached in that
game karana versus carlson uh where fabi
went for knight to g5 maybe remember it
as the knights are so nicely placed on
the fifth rank all three of them and
then white has some ideas of maybe queen
f3 going after
some uh very very nice ideas here uh but
uh this was not played in this game in
this game uh alireza just castled and it
is now only as of move seven that we
have a completely new game so rapport
takes this uh moment of uh
uh clarity basically to to get rid of
this knife from b5 with a6 not bringing
the knight back right away but first c4
saying okay if your calculator i'm going
to capture on d5 and have a beautiful
center here so instead after c4 we have
knight back to b4 or rather forward
and now we're asking white what do you
do with your knight knight plays knight
to c3 and now uh you could go for knight
to d3 but even though it seems like it
prevents y from developing like it's a
really nice idea just queen e2 and what
is your knight really doing there if
knight captures on c1 rook captures
you've basically helped white to develop
his entire queen side that's not
something you want to do
you want to force white to play either
d3 or d4 move the bishop and then
somehow bring the rick into the game you
don't want to allow all those things to
happen with just one move so instead we
have d6 and now d4 striking in the
center c captures on d4 uh and we have
to go back one move because uh
okay we're in the sicilian defense it's
very natural to play d4 but you always
have to be careful of playing d4 when
the knight is on b4 here all it is i
played the d4 and it seems very forcing
but uh
what's really happening here c captures
on d4 and now the problem is if you
capture with the knight you lose control
of the e5 square and if you capture with
the queen of course knight the sea to
check forks the queen and the rook and
this is the uh moment where the magic
happens here ali is a dust capture with
queen characters on the four and he
offers that up or this beautiful knight
the c2 fork uh going for the queen and
the rook so you have to play this
otherwise i mean you you you are not a
chess player if you don't go after this
so knight's the c2 attacking the queen
and the rook and now queen to e4 getting
the queen away from the d file but also
just putting pressure on that knight
saying uh you now have to capture on a1
and so what does we have knight captures
on a1 and now bishop to f4 here you have
to decide whether you want to keep this
knight here for a little bit longer
maybe not develop right away maybe play
rook to d1
and then put a lot of pressure on black
but black maybe can play bishop to e6
and uh well uh it's anyone's guess who's
better in this position because uh it
has never been reached before and it's
uh
uh quite a lot to consider definitely uh
but okay now in the game after this uh
captures of a1 we have bishop to f4 now
alireza is ready to
recapture on a1 uh we have bishop to a6
always useful to put something in
between here so if something like he
captures and d6 happens you can capture
with the captures and d6 without
worrying about opening up the e file so
rook captures on a1 and now rook the c8
bishop to e6 rook the c8 idea comes with
tempo is now the rook characters on c4
is the idea we're going after white's
queen
so here you have to decide do you play
b4 guard the c for pawn and then allow
an active move like queen to a5 going
after the knight here or do you play
what alireza played in the game and that
is knight to d5 you block the bishop's
attack towards the
c4 pawn
and you ask what can black play here and
now there are many things you can play
here but
not a lot of things that are actually
good uh so if you try to castle and well
it's very unrealistic to think that
you're gonna move the bishop play seven
bishop to uh some like e7 bishop e7 and
castle uh maybe try g6 but this uh
completely falls apart just e captures
on d6 e captures on d6 and now bishop to
g5 and that's the game uh the black
queen does not have a good square if you
play bishop b7 we just capture that the
knight and bishop are covering that
square and if you play something like
queen a5 just b4 and what do you play
here queen a4 now comes knight to d4 and
well black is just falling apart here
there is no defense here so instead
after knight to d5 we have the very uh
well natural d captures on e5 it is by
far the best move
knight captures an e5 by ferruja and now
again what do you play here it's such a
crazy position and this especially this
position is uh where i really want you
to have the idea of the tournament
happening where
uh magnus is playing against nipple if
magnus wins of course uh he wins first
place even if it's a drawing magnus wins
the armageddon magnus still wins first
place probably
but if nepo beats magnus and uh well of
course that can happen uh then uh these
two will be playing for first place and
uh you you want to play the absolute
best move so here if you want to just
trade down and make the position equal
you can play rook captures on c4 that's
not the problem queen captures and now
you're going to play queen captures on
d5
and black is very happy here you don't
really have anything to worry about
but rapper 2 wants to play the absolute
best move however
rook captures on c4 is not the absolute
best and neither is the move that he
played he played f6 here and it's very
close to the actual best move the best
move here is g6 and now
uh the problem is after rook the d1
white doesn't really have any threats
here yes you are
threatening to move the knight but we're
just going to play bishop to g7 we even
encourage white to move the knight here
because if something like knight to f6
check we are very happy to give up the
queen here he captures on f6 rook
capture 78 with check rook captures and
now
uh rook to d1 will be checkmate and also
your knight is being threatened so your
only move is knight to f3 we're still
going to play rogue d1 check knight to
e1 and now we're just gonna castle to
safety and here uh white is completely
busted he might play some like h3 to
create some breeding room for king we're
going to play f5 we unleash the
well the power of this bishop pair we
have a beautiful rook here the other
rook is coming to the open d file uh
black is just uh
but black is winning here regardless of
who is playing black so g6 for rapport
does wonders however f6 the move he
played uh allows all it is that uh uh
kind of grab the initiative so here um
you could go for knight to g6 yes the
bishop here is kind of awkwardly placed
but if you go for this then h captures
on g6 queen captures an e6 and rook to
c6 sorry that's not a c6 work to c6 and
black is perfectly fine there's nothing
to worry about here
so instead after f6 we have knight back
to f3 by furuja
and now comes the bishop captures on d5
and this is the
uh
basically the last moment where rapper
should have uh found something better
but the the time consumption in these
positions is simply insane uh just for
rujo when he after he decided to give up
the rook on a1 he spent some 40 minutes
deciding on what to play next and even
though he knew what he was going to play
i guess he maybe prepared it maybe you
know a long long time ago and then he
was just trying to remember lines or
maybe this entire thing was just an over
the board inspiration it's hard to say i
haven't um uh caught uh the the
interview with ferocious so if you guys
have insight on that uh do share so we
can all learn a little bit but yeah here
king to f7 is the main idea uh you have
to bring the king to f7 get the king
away from this uh
e8 square and also from the range of
this knight
and now you really don't have all that
much if you play rook to d1 it's not a
problem just queen d7 we don't care
i mean the knight cannot move you can't
move the knight with check and the rook
on d1 would be hanging and if you play
rook to e1 going after the bishop here
we're just going to capture the knight
on d5 c captures queen d7 sorry queen d7
and we're perfectly fine here is black
so this is what uh should be played
however after knight to f3
uh rapper decided to eliminate one of
the attackers i mean it's the principal
thing you do you're getting attacked
your opponent sacrifice material you
want to trade down and remove as many
attackers as possible c captures on d5
and now rook to c5 going after this d5
pawn but now d6 by ferruja and now what
do you play here well uh e6 obviously
doesn't work we're just gonna capture it
but what about e5 it seems like such a
great move uh but uh only seemingly
because this loses the game terribly
yeah after e4 after e5 attacking the
bishop uh i don't even have to tell you
anymore what the best movies the best
movies of course b4 and that's always
the best move just attacking that rook
and we we want to remove the rook from
the defense of the e5 pawn rook the b5
with a for now with a second attack on
the rook and now finally after the rook
moves
we sacrifice the knight here and now it
doesn't matter what black plays the the
entire position just falls apart for
example captures we're going to capture
with check now if you go here then we
have queen f5 check if you go here we
have queen to d5 check and of course if
you block with the bishop
which seems like okay you want to give
some material back but it just rook to
e1 and that's it there's no defense here
rook captures on d6 is met by queen
captures on d6 queen captures bishop
captures and uh we're going to capture
on e7 as well so king the d7 and i know
you guys really want to capture with the
bishop but that's actually not the way
to go then rook to e8 poses a lot of
problems for white you have to give back
the piece real captures on e7 king
captures now bishop rook capture spawn
on b7 and now you have this position
where you're up uh two pawns and of
course you have a completely winning
endgame
uh so that's what happens if in this
position after d6 uh you play a move
like e5 but of course queen to d7 was
played this is the absolute best move
preparing e6
and now we have b4 uh further attacking
this rook we want to play a4 as well
and now you have to play rook to c8 it's
an ugly move to play but we still need
to play it and after work to d1 king f7
this king has to move away from e8 but
rapport fails to do that
uh on
you know many occasions so here at upper
plays rook to c6 i guess it does make
sense maybe now e5 maybe you can capture
maybe you can play king to f7 next and
then have more support for capturing on
d6
but it simply doesn't work now here
alireza plays rook to e1 and now rapper
does play king to f7 but now comes
knight to d4 and what do you play here
such an ugly position uh the problem is
if you move rook uh to c8 now it's not
enough we're just gonna play queen to d5
check king to e8 and now knight to e6
and you don't have a defense here we're
we're threatening to capture the bishop
here once rook or king captures we're
gonna capture an e7 and there's nothing
you can do about this uh on the other
hand if you capture on d6 we're just
gonna capture with a discovery here
after king captures just bishop captures
on v6 with check and the black king has
no square available for him so you have
to give up the queen here and of course
it's game over
uh so after this knight to d4 move uh
what do you play well we now have e5 now
it's actually the only move for black
but now comes queen to d5 with check
and now uh it's uh well it's a pretty
pretty
uh crazy possession uh king to g6 was
played uh but this is simply uh
impossible to stop now feel free to
pause the video and win the game for uh
alireza while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding the
only move that wins the game for white
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's bishop captures an
e5 so to uh to whoever who found this uh
congratulations you are an excellent
spotter of you know unique winning moves
uh and before we check out what happened
in the game i would just like to mention
that king the g6 was played but king the
e8 uh would give a rapport a bit more uh
fighting chances because now if bishop
captures an e5f captures we play queen
captures an e5 now you have king to d8
and here uh it's uh well okay of course
you capture with check you're going to
play queen captures on c6 and now we
have this position where white is better
but it's not easy to to find the way to
continue with white uh the position is
winning for white but it's uh you have
to find the engine move and that is a4
i'm only showing you this so you see how
rich any position can be and now the
problem is uh if you capture here for
example queen captures an a4 then we
play d7 and now there is no defense if
queen captures on these seven k uh of
course we're going to play first uh
queen to c8 with the check the rook
covers the entire uh e file so here
we're gonna block and then rook to d1
check king has to move and we're gonna
capture the queen so of course that's
impossible uh after a4 you will not be
able to capture that pawn you're gonna
play i have to play something like h6
and then the game continues uh with
white having excellent chances for
uh for achieving something in this
position but okay in the actual game
king the g6 was played and now comes
bishop captures on e5 the move you all
found uh we have rook captures and d6
the problem with capturing an e5 is that
alireza had mine knight to f3 now you're
threatening knight captures an e5 check
forking the king and the queen and even
if queen captures here you just deliver
this check king to f6 and now queen to
f7 check and you get to this beautiful
morphe-like checkmate king g5 f4 with
checking h4 g3 with checking h3 and king
queen to f5 with checkmate so just uh
incredible stuff so after bishop
captures an e5 we have rook captures and
these six by rapport uh and now comes
bishop captures and e6 and unfortunately
you can't even develop your bishop
or rather you can't you can develop your
bishop but you can't even uh trade
queens here if you play queen captures
on d6 you run into queen e4 check king
to f7 now queen to e8 check you have to
develop the bishop so the rogue gains
control of this king g8 and now knight
f5 attacks the queen and it's game over
once the queen moves 97 wins the game
whatever you play 97 just wins the game
uh that's it you're you're in check you
can't move the bishop you have to
capture with the queen and then just
recaptures on a7 and black has no moves
here
so after bishop captures on e6 we have
bishop captures on d6 okay now the rook
can enter the game but now uh the bishop
cannot move the queen and d7 will be
hanging and that's a problem we have
queen to e for checkbile it is a king to
f7 now queen to d5 check repeating the
position a little bit uh checking what
rapport will do and now of course you
can't just remain here bishop captures
an h2 check would win the queen so you
have to play g3 allow black one move of
consolidation but one move of
consolidation is not enough he plays h6
uh tries to create some breeding room
for his king on h7 but now rook to d1
now you are putting insane pressure here
on the bishop and
like i said the bishop cannot move the
queen and d7 would hang
and if you play something like rook to
d8 we just play knight to e6 we kick
away the rook and then we pick up the
bishop here there is nothing you can do
here so instead after rook to d1 we rook
the e8 but still nothing knight to f3 uh
we have rooked a6 now we're threatening
to win material here with queen captures
on d6
so rook to e6 defending
and then now comes knight to h4 with
check king to h7 and now the position is
again completely winning for white
however there is only one winning move
for white here
so feel free to pause the video for the
second time and find this incredible
move for alireza while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations i'm not playing
knight to fr right away i know you guys
want to attack this bishop three times
but if you play knight to f5 right away
rook to e5 and you don't have a win
anymore now the knight is hanging the
queen is hanging and if you play queen
captures on e6 we just play queen
captures on f5 and the material is equal
the game continues uh not much for you
to do here so for those of you who found
the actual winning move and that's queen
to d3 with check not allowing rook to e5
to come with the tempo on the queen
congratulations you have just created a
sort of a mini game of the century as
this is basically what it is i think uh
this game by ferruja uh just giving up
the rook like that on a1 and just
playing this brilliant brilliant game
against uh someone who was leading the
tournament so far and this you know
fighting for the top is is definitely
something to be considered a mini game
of the century so here queen to d3 check
and now it doesn't matter what black
plays king take it or king to j2 we
usually don't want to run into check
uh the the game would continue but after
queen to d3 check uh it was in this
position that richard rapport resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here like i said if you move king
they said or king g8 now comes knight f5
and there's no defense we have a we are
attacking the bishop three times you
can't move it otherwise the queen falls
and whatever you play we just capture
here and that's it we wrap a piece
completely winning king of f8 uh and you
know anything pretty much wins here but
we have to be very careful when we say
anything wins because here uh you might
you know play some like knight to f5 and
say okay let's trade queens i'm
completely winning here and then you run
into rook to e1 check something you know
that might happen to you in online chess
and i'm sure it does as it happens to
everyone and then you think okay if i if
i capture the rook i'm going to lose my
queen so obviously i'm going to play
king to g2 but then rook d1 and now what
do you play you're down here down the
exchange if you trade you just go into
an end game a night against the rook so
you were completely winning one moment
and then you know
uh you relaxed maybe a little bit too
fast and then your opponent completely
took advantage of this so now even
though you're the one that's uh
threatening this and it's your opponent
whose bishop is pinned
you know you always have to be careful
of moves like this just something i
wanted to mention so now before we
forget let's check out the standings
after all the rounds of the norway chess
2021 magnus carlsen wins the tournament
with 19 and a half followed by alireza
ferruga whoever takes rapport here in
the final round by beating him with 18
points then rihard rapport with 16 and a
half yanni pomishi the world's
championship challenger uh with 12
points sergey karakin with 10 and
arientari with seven points and what
does this mean uh for the world top ten
rankings let's check it out so there you
have it uh uh both ferruccia and rapport
broke into the world top ten there we
have it 2770 both of them okay firuja 27
70.2 so rapper ninten plays feruja in
ninth uh and we'll see how uh this will
evolve but as you can see they've won a
lot of points for classical chess no one
wins that many points it's uh crazy to
win that many points in classical
tournament
and then you have magnus magnus in the
first place with
28 54.8
he wins the tournament he wins the
classical tournament and he loses rating
points that's the problem of being so
much higher rated than everyone else
because even if you slip just a little
bit you're not going to be gaining
rating points of course you will be
losing them every draw for magnus is a
loss of rating points and then he has to
make up for it by winning the games but
even as he does you can see that it's
not enough so he wins such a such strong
tournament like norwich has but still he
loses rating points that's uh you know
the curse of being much higher rated
than everyone else uh but yeah uh those
were the standings and the well current
development of the world's top 20. hope
you guys enjoyed that uh i would like to
thank uh or rather wish a happy birthday
to matthew tabu i would like to thank
felipe giorgio dimitri samsonov now john
dogdale and author fan faceoff for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it uh as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you for watching and i will
see you soon checking out whatever else
is happening in the chess world of
course checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else uh
uh happens in the chess world uh so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
uh well really hope you guys enjoyed
this game because i i enjoyed it
immensely uh see you soon